Guten Tag, mein Name ist Sumera Firat, ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistant Arztin tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden erzählen, würde ich Ihnen gerne ein paar Allgemeinfragen stellen.
Wie heißen Sie das?
Ich heiße Manfred Holthkamp.
Manfred Holthkamp.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich bestebieren?
Ja, Manfred, M-A-N-F-R-E-D, Manfred.
Und Holthkamp, H-O-L-T-K-A-M-P, Holthkamp.
Um sicher zu sein, bestebiere ich noch einmal.
Manfred, Schreibsicht M-A-N-F-R-E-W-M-R-T, Holthkamp, Schreibsicht H-O-L-T-K-A-M-P.
Genau.
Herr Manfred Holthkamp, spreche ich Ihren Namen richtig aus?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie Herr Holthkamp?
Ich bin 62 Jahre alt.
62 Jahre alt? Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 21. Oktober 1963.
Okay, 21. Sente 1963.
Ja.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Holthkamp?
1,76 m.
1,76 m? Wie viel wiegen Sie?
90 kg.
Okay.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Sie heute so uns, Herr Holthkamp?
Ja, seit ungefähr 3 Stunden geht es mir nicht gut.
Mir ist unwohl, mir ist übel, ich habe einmal erbrochen.
Ich habe so einen Druckschmerz im Brustkorb und im Oberbauch.
Ja.
Das tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Bescheid haben.
Seit 3 Stunden haben Sie Übelkeit und noch einmal erbrochen
und Druckschmerzen im Brustkorb und im Oberbauch.
Hab ich richtig verstanden.
Ja.
Okay.
Können Sie mir genau zeigen, wo Sie diese Brustschmerzen haben?
Ganz im Brustkorb oder hinter dem Brustbein?
Ja, es ist schon im Brustkorb, aber hauptsächlich hinter dem Brustbein.
Hauptsächlich?
Ja.
Bezüglich hierher ist der Oberbauch.
Sind die Schmerzen in der Mitte rechts oder links?
Mehr in der Mitte, vielleicht ein bisschen links, aber hauptsächlich ist der Schmerz im Brustkorb.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen plötsch oder langsam aufgetreten?
Im Holthkamp.
Na, also schon relativ plötzlich, relativ schnell.
Gibt es eine?
Innerhalb weniger Minuten.
Okay.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslösung für die Schmerzen?
Zum Beispiel haben Sie sich vielleicht verletzt oder haben Sie etwas besonders gegessen?
Nein, verletzt habe ich mich nicht.
Ich habe heute am Vormittag, weil es ja draußen stark geschneit hat,
musste ich Schnee räumen.
Den Schnee wegräumen vom Bürgersteig von der Straße musste ich sauber machen.
Das war schon etwas anstrengend.
Ja, verstehe.
Danach sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie mit weg?
Die sind dauerhaft.
Dauerhaft, okay.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus, zum Beispiel in den linken Arm oder in den Hals?
Ne, ne.
Eigentlich mehr, wie gesagt, hinter dem Brustwein und oben im Bauch.
Ja, okay, verstehe ich.
Leiden Sie unter auf Luftnot, Herzrasen, kaltschweiß?
Ja, Luftnot so ein bisschen.
Das spüre ich.
Ich traue mich auch gar nicht so richtig tief zu atmen, aber ich muss etwas schneller atmen, vielleicht.
Ja, ich habe auch mal so ein Schweißausbruch gehabt, vielleicht wegen der Schmerzen, ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, okay.
Herr Holkamp, können Sie mir sagen, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkalaform 1 bis 10 vorbei?
1,30 Schmerzen sind sehr starker Schmerzen einspricht.
Ja, ich würde sagen schon 6 bis 7.
Oh, 6 bis 7, okay.
Herr Holkamp, ich möchte Sie nicht beunruhigen, aber Sie haben typische Beschwerden einer Herzkrankheit.
Deswegen möchte ich, so seit das Gespräch unterbrechen,
und ich werde Ihre Vitalparameter überprüfen und ein EKG schreiben und Ihnen etwas Blut abnehmen und das bestätigen.
Ja, was heißt Vitalparameter?
Vitalparameter, was heißt das?
Ja, Vitalparameter umfasst Ihre Blutdruck, Ihre Temperatur und Ihre Herzfrühe, Atemfrühe.
Ah, so, ja, okay.
Ja, das können wir machen.
Ja, wie Sie wissen, jetzt, momentan, sind wir berufen, können wir das Gespräch weiterführen?
Ja.
Okay.
Herr Holkamp, ist es das erste Mal oder hatten Sie schon früh einige Symptome?
Also, ich habe in letzter Zeit so bemerkt, dass ich beim Treppensteigen oder wenn ich etwas getragen habe,
dass ich da auch schnell mal so etwas Luftnot bekam.
Und dann musste ich eine Pause machen.
Und ja, das war so in den letzten Wochen.
Aber ich habe das nicht so richtig ernst genommen.
Okay.
Waren Sie deswegen beim Haus erst?
Nein, noch nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie heute etwas gegen Schmerzen angenommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, nein, nicht.
Nur meine normalen Medikamente?
Normale Medikamente.
Okay.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie? Normale?
Ja, ich habe ja auch hohen Blutdruck, schon seit ungefähr 15 Jahren.
Und ich nehme, ich habe hier ein Zettel, BISO-Prolol, heißt das Mittel.
Da nehme ich...
Da steht Dosierung.
Dahinter steht fünf.
Und da nehme ich zwei Tabletten pro Tag.
Einmal morgens, einmal abends.
Und da nehme ich noch RAMI-Pril.
Ein Bömpf steht da auch hinter.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine halbe Tablette abends.
Und ich nehme noch FUROSI mit.
Davon muss ich häufig dann Wasser lassen, schnell.
FUROSI mit, dahinter steht zehn.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und ich nehme noch etwas gegen mein hohes Cholesterin.
Das heißt ROSU-Vastatin.
Da steht 20 dahinter, 20.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette abends.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Holkamp, Sie haben auch einmal Erbrüchen.
Wie sagt das Erbrüchen aus?
Das war so ein bisschen noch etwas vom Frühstück.
Weil ich ja vorher auch ein bisschen gefrühstückt hatte noch.
Das war etwas Brot und etwas Käse.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie Sotbränen oder Souris aufstößen haben?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Oder haben Sie eine geschwollenes, gerötetes oder überwarmte Spanen bemerkt?
Nein, manchmal sind meine Füße abends, die Unterschenkel am Knöchel,
etwas geschwollen abends.
Aber morgens sind sie dann wieder dünner.
Ich muss auch nachts zweimal auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Mein Hausarzt sagt, das hängt etwas mit meinem Herzen zusammen.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschweite?
Seit einem Jahr.
Ich nehme dieses eine Mittel, das über die Designiere wirkt.
Das nehme ich jetzt seit ungefähr zwei Jahren.
Solange ungefähr habe ich dieses mit den Beinschwellungen.
Im Sommer, wenn es warm ist, ist das stärker.
Ich verstehe, das ist ja auch nicht gut.
Herr Holkamp, ich werde Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Allgemeinen Zustand stellen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe aber nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht vom Gefühl her.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stülfrost, Nachschweiß?
Stülfrost habe ich auch nicht.
Aber ich habe eben, als das mit den Schmerzen anfing,
etwas stärker geschwitzt.
Ja, ich habe es notiert.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Zu gut.
Ich wege auch zu viel.
Ich muss immer aufpassen.
Ja, das freut mich, dass Sie bemerkt haben.
Ja, aber auch nicht so geschafft.
Ich muss mich mehr bewegen.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Das ist nicht einfach.
Aber das ist sehr gut, dass Sie versucht.
Ich grüße Sie.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gewicht abgenommen oder so genommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Ich schlafe von Sie gut?
Normalerweise gut.
Aber manchmal habe ich auch Spätdienst.
Ich bin Taxifahrer von Beruf.
Und dann kann ich manchmal nicht so gut danach schlafen.
Wenn ich erst so um Mitternacht nach Hause komme,
dann ist man nicht so gut.
Okay, wegen Spätschift.
Ja, verstehe ich.
Sie haben nächtliche Wasserlassen.
Außer nächtliche Wasserlassen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Wie ist es mit dem Stuhlgang?
Alles in Ordnung?
Stuhlgang ist regelmäßig.
Jeden Tag habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Das ist gut.
Ich werde jetzt ein paar Fragen Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen.
Sie leiden an.
Die Mutter ist 15 Jahre alt.
Und sie haben Hochscholesterie.
Ja, vielleicht seit fünf Jahren.
Gibt es noch andere krönliche Erkrankungen bei Ihnen?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine krönischen Erkrankungen.
Herr Holkamp, messen Sie regelmäßig Ihren Blutdruck?
Na, früher mehr.
In letzter Zeit nicht mehr so oft.
Meine Frau sagt immer, du musst das häufiger kontrollieren.
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe vor drei Wochen gemessen.
Da war er vielleicht 145 zu 90.
Ich müsste es häufiger tun.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich operiert am Blinddarm.
Da war ich 9 Jahre alt.
Und dann hatte ich einen Bruch vom linken Schienenbein durch Fußball spielen.
Da war ich 25 Jahre alt.
Das musste auch operiert werden.
Sind beide Operationen gut verlofst?
Ja, ja.
Super.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig Biso pro Loll, Ramipril, Furusemid, Rosa Vasatin.
Gibt es noch andere Medikamente?
Nein, sonst nehme ich nichts.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas? Herr Holkamp, vielleicht Polen?
Ja, ich bin allergisch gegen Nickel.
Nickel.
Das habe ich gemerkt an einem Gürtel.
Dass ein Ausschlag kam am Gürtel.
Dann wurde das getestet beim Hautarzt.
Dann hat er gesagt, das ist eine Nickelallergie.
Okay.
Vertragen Sie alle Nahrungsmittel mit Kulitanfutter?
Ja, da vertrag ich alles.
Super. Darf ich fragen, ob Sie rauchen?
Ja, wie ich rauche.
Ich rauche schon lange.
45 Jahre rauche ich schon.
20 Zigaretten am Tag.
Also eine Schachtel.
Das ist so viel.
Ja, das sagen alle.
Das sagt meine Frau, das sagen meine Kinder, das sagt der Arzt.
Aber Beruf als Taxifahrer ist immer viel Stress.
Die Kollegen rauchen auch alle.
Es ist schwierig.
Das ist sehr schwierig.
Aber wenn Sie möchten, kann ich Ihnen gerne ein spezielles Namen fehlten
und Unterrichtsschritte zu behalten.
Können wir dann später darüber sprechen.
Ja, okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber unregelmäßig,
weil ich muss ja auch beim Taxifahren trinke ich kein Alkohol.
Natürlich trinke ich mal abends eine kleine Flasche Bier.
Aber das ist nicht jeden Abend.
Okay.
Bier, nicht jeden Abend.
Wie viel mal trinken Sie?
Nur eine kleine Flasche.
Ja, vielleicht viermal die Woche.
Bitte nehmen Sie mir nächste Frage nicht, oder?
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Nehmen Sie irgendwann eine Droge?
Nein.
Keine.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund
oder gibt es chronische Erkrankungen bei Ihren Eltern?
Herr Holkamp.
Also der Vater ist verstorben.
Da war er 74 Jahre alt an einem Herzinfarkt.
Das tut mir leid für Sie.
Die Mutter ist im Alter von 70 Jahren verstorben.
Die hatte Blutkrebs.
Das tut mir leid.
Wirklich.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Der ist zwei Jahre älter als ich.
Der hatte auch hohen Blutdruck
und hatte vor zwei Jahren eine Operation am Herzen.
Da wurden ihm, wie nennt sich das,
Beipäse gelegt.
Beipass-Operationen.
Das heißt, richtig.
Traben Sie Sport, Herr Holkamp?
Früher.
Früher habe ich Sport gemacht, ja Fußball gespielt.
Deswegen damals auch die Verletzung, Beinbruch.
Aber ich jetzt bestimmt seit 20 Jahren
mache gar nichts mehr, kein Sport.
Ja, richtig.
Und dann ist das Körpergewicht hochgegangen.
Leben Sie mit Ihrem Frau?
Ja, wir wohnen zusammen.
Wir haben zwei Kinder, die sind aber schon beide über 30 Jahre alt.
Die leben aber nicht mehr bei uns.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja.
Sie haben viel Stress bei der Arbeit,
aber haben Sie Stress im Privatleben?
Nein, nein.
Die Arbeit ist der Stress.
Herr Holkamp, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen geschiteilt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen
oder haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich möchte, dass bald meine Beschwerden besser werden,
dass es mir wieder besser geht.
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Holkamp, ich werde Ihnen
eine Körperleutzerung machen.
Wir haben schon Ihre Viterprimente überprüft
und einen EKG geschrieben und etwas Blut abnehmen.
Aber ich werde auf eine Herzultraschall
und Bachultraschall durchführen.
Natürlich werde ich Ihre EKG erneut machen.
Sobald Ihre Befundung vorliegt,
besprechen Sie Ihre Situation mit meinem Oberarzt
und kommen Ihre Eklare in den Alles schrittwürst.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Okay, das können wir so machen.
Danke.
Also, Sie haben jetzt ein bisschen Zeit.
Denken Sie daran die Übersetzung der Patientensprache
in die Fachbegriffe, wenn das geht.
Die Kollegen und Kolleginnen, heute sind wir ja relativ viele,
haben vielleicht noch Fragen oder Ergänzungen.
Es ist schon sehr viel gefragt worden
und auch sehr verständlich.
Gut, gute Verständigung, das war alles gut.
Gibt es noch Ergänzungen?
Die Kollegen sind mit Ihnen zufrieden?
Das war eine Frage.
Bitte.
Was ist das für eine kardiologische Untersuchung?
Beim Kardiologen bin ich noch nie gewesen.
Ich gehe zum Hausarzt.
Da gehe ich einmal im Jahr hin.
Da misst dann auch das Blut,
das Cholesterinspiegel und macht auch ein EKG.
Und macht auch eine,
muss ich so in Apparatpusten, Lungenfunktion.
Und der Hausarzt sagt eben,
ja, der Blutdruck ist nicht so ganz optimal eingestellt.
Und das Körpergewicht müsste eigentlich runter.
Und natürlich auch das Rauchen ist ein Problem.
Aber es ist alles für mich schwierig, das zu verändern.
Ich verstehe.
Gut, wenn jetzt im Augenblick keine Fragen sind,
dann lasse ich die Kolleginnen jetzt etwas in Ruhe,
dass sie sich etwas vorbereiten können.
Das ist ja auch ein Problem.
Ich sage mal so in fünf Minuten,
komme ich wieder und dann besprechen wir den Fall.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, das ist in Ordnung für mich.
Gut, bis gleich.
Okay.
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Sumera Firat.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten abgenommen.
Darf ich vorstellen?
Ja, bitte.
Ich bin der Mannfred Holkamp.
Er ist 62 Jahre alt und am 21.10.1900,
63 geboren.
Er ist 1 Meter, 76 groß und wiegt 90 Kilogramm.
Er stellt sich bei uns wegen seit 3 Stunden bestehenden
retrosternalen Torekalgien
und epigasrische Abdominalschmerzen vor.
Laut Aussagen des Patienten sind die Schmerzen plötzlich
bei Nachdenbelastung aufgetreten.
Er berichtet, dass die Schmerzen drückend persistierend sind.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala.
Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus.
Er begleitet, klagt über Dispner,
Takipe, Hyperhydroase, Neusea,
einmalige Vomitus, das mit Essen resteht.
Ja, vegetativ anamnestisch.
Er gab sich nicht durch
wegen Schichterarbeit,
manihmal, disson-li.
Ja, bei der Foyacrank anamnese
erwente er am arterielle Hypertonie
seit 5 Jahren,
und Hypercholestrenie
zustand nach appendectomy mit 9 Lebensia
und Libia, linker Libia fraktur
mit 5 und 20 Lebensia.
Bei der Medikamentanamnese
er gab sich die Einnahme von Bisoprolol, 5 mg,
einmal morgens, einmal abends,
Ramipril, 5 mg, einmal morgens,
1,5 abends,
Früße mit 10 mg, einmal morgens,
Rosovastatin, 20 mg, einmal abends.
Die allergie-nanamnese er gab allergie gegen Nikkel,
die sich exantem oysert.
Bei den oxananamnese erwente er
circa 5 und 20 Packiers
und ein klein Flasche Biya,
4 Mal pro Woche,
mit der drogen Konsum wurden verneint.
Die Familienanamnese ergab
Myocardinfarkt beim Vata,
mit 4 und 7 Lebensia gestorben.
Verdacht auf Lekemi
bei der Mutter,
mit 7 Cent Lebensia gestorben.
70, 70, nicht 17, 70.
Artilleri per Toni,
beim Bruder,
sein Bruder,
wo es war,
eine Korinne bei Passo,
die Durche für die Sozialanamnese ist.
Er ist Taxifahrer vom Beruf,
er ist verheiratet, lebt mit ihrer Frau.
Seiner Frau, seiner, seiner Frau.
Seiner Frau, hat zwei Kinder,
die sind auf der Erdbeutung,
seine Frau, hat zwei Kinder.
Er hat viel Stress bei der Arbeit,
leider treibt er keinen Sport.
Ja, die Anamnestik, oder?
Ja, haben Sie bei dieser Beschwerdesymptomatik
die Vita-Parameter kontrolliert im Anfang?
Ja, am Anfang habe ich die Vita-Parameter
überprüft, ein EKG geschrieben
und etwas Blut abgenommen.
Okay, gut, prima.
Die Werte waren so weit in Ordnung, die Vita-Parameter?
Ja, die Vita-Parameter und EKG sind alle Ordnung,
dann habe ich das Gespräch weitergemacht.
Ja, okay, sehr gut.
Eine kurze Frage, der Patient nimmt auch ein Dioretikum,
Furu Semit, hat er auch Ödeme?
Ja, er hat besonders am Abends geschwollene Beine.
Ja, sagen Sie ruhig Unterschenkel.
Ja, sagen Sie ruhig Unterschenkel-Ödeme oder Knöchel-Ödeme?
Ja, Unterschenkel und Knöchel-Ödeme.
Deswegen war er beim Hausarzt
und Hausarzt hat ihm eine Fursse mit verschoben.
Okay, gut.
Und er hat glaube ich 2-malige Nüktorie, haben Sie gesagt?
Ja, 2-malige Nüktorie.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, die Anamelistischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf
Akut-Korinther-Sendrom hin.
Ja, Retrosternale Buruschimertsön, Obabauchschimertsön,
auch Dispne, Takiplne, Hyperhidrosa,
Neusea-Shiprachen-Daföö,
Differenzialdiagnostischkommen, Lungenarteriellenbolie,
Art desektions oder Gastroesophagell-Reflügskrankheit im Betracht.
Okay, gut, prima.
Ja, bin ich mit einverstanden, sehr schön, haben Sie es sehr gut gemacht.
Gut, ich habe Sie gut verstanden.
Sie haben das sehr gut strukturiert
und haben auch die Fachbegriffe, denke ich,
sehr gut bewusst und eingebunden in die Vorstellung.
Wichtig war, dass Sie im Anfang bei dieser Beschwerdesymptomatik
die Vitalparameter erst kontrolliert haben, unterbrochen haben.
Das ist sehr wichtig und ist auch in einer Prüfung sicherlich
dann sehr wichtig, dass Sie das tun, wenn so etwas ist.
Lieber einmal mehr machen, als zu wenig, sage ich.
Lieber bei bestimmten Dingen, wo Sie nicht sicher sind,
sagen Sie, ich messe jetzt erst mal Ihren Blutdruck
und messe vielleicht Ihren Sauerstoffgehalt im Blut
und mache eine EKG, dann fühle ich mich sicherer
und kann mir schon einen besseren Eindruck verschaffen.
Das beruhigt den Patienten
und ist auch für Sie selber, denke ich, von Wichtigkeit
und es ist auch gut vor der Prüfungskommission.
Sie haben das sehr gut, auch verständlich,
von der Sprache her, denke ich, sehr gut gemacht
und gut der Verdacht auf ein gutes Coronasyndrom.
Der ist sicherlich natürlich naheliegend,
aber trotzdem gibt es bestimmte Verdachtdiagnosen
oder Differenzialdiagnosen, die haben Sie aber gut gesagt.
Ein Kollege hat, glaube ich, noch geschrieben,
Herzinsuffizienz.
Vielleicht hat der Patient auch inzwischen
wahrscheinlich durch die Hypertonie bedingte Herzinsuffizienz,
er hat auch viele Risikofaktoren,
natürlich durch den Nikotinabusos, den langjährigen
und sehr stressigen Beruf.
Er hat eine positive Familienanamnese
durch den Vater, durch den Bruder.
Das sind alles Faktoren, die an so etwas auch denken lassen.
Gut, prima, vielen Dank.
Wann machen Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Nächster Montag.
Ja, also, das werden Sie super schaffen.
Wo machen Sie die?
Im Düsseldorf.
Ja, schön.
Ja, gut, hat mir viel Spaß gemacht
und danke auch für die Kollegen,
aber Sie haben gemerkt, die Kollegen haben
wenig Fragen gestellt, weil Sie vorher alles schon gefragt haben.
Nein, es wurden wenig Fragen gestellt.
Gut, danke.
Ich würde sagen, ich wünsche Ihnen allen
einen schönen Abend noch und Ihnen eine gute Prüfung.